ist das jetzt eine katastrophe oder eine
wirklich gute idee eine batterie die auf
radioaktivität basierte forschungsteams
weltweit arbeiten daran aus
radioaktivität elektrische energie zu
gewinnen und jetzt meldet ein russisches
forschungsteam einen überraschenden
durchbruch ein prototyp der fast zehn
mal so viel energie fast wie eine
vergleichbare elektrochemische batterie
was ist dran an dieser meldung und wie
genau soll das funktionieren
jetzt ein klick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
die idee batterien auf basis von
radioaktivität zu entwickeln ist nicht
neu vor allem in der mitte des letzten
jahrhunderts wurden einzig und allein
die positiven seiten der radioaktivität
gesehen nicht nur autos flugzeuge und
schiffe sollten günstig und schnell mit
atomantrieb laufen sondern
beispielsweise auch herzschrittmacher
und so entwickelte man schrittmacher die
durch eine radionuklid batterie
angetrieben wurden
darin enthalten bis zu 200 milligramm
plutonium 238 und einen alphastrahler
mit einer halbwertszeit von 87 jahren
und die batterie funktioniert
folgendermaßen eine thermo säule wurde
durch den radioaktiven zerfall erhitzt
und eine elektrische spannung entstand
mit der der herzschrittmacher
angetrieben wurde und tatsächlich die
plutonium batterien waren extrem lange
haltbar und lieferten jahrzehnte lang
strom doch er wisse selbst plutonium
gilt selbst in kleinsten mengen als sehr
sehr gefährlich und so nahm man bald
wieder abstand von dieser idee andere
entwicklungen in diesem kontext dann
meistens nicht praxistauglich was waren
sie einfach viel zu klobig um im alltag
eingesetzt zu werden
die neue batterie die jetzt ein
russisches forschungsteam entwickelt hat
die nutzt radioaktives nicke 63 als
energiequelle die halbwertszeit von
nickel 63 die liegt bei rund 100 jahren
und nur das begrenzt die lebensdauer der
batterie konkret besteht die batterie
aus zwei dünnen schichten nickel 63
folie
diese sind eingebettet in diamant
schichten und so genannten schottky
dioden das sorgt dafür dass der strom
nur in eine richtung fließen kann
konkret entsteht der strom
wenn nickel 63 zerfällt und dabei beta
teilchen entstehen die crux ball nuklear
batterien die wir bislang so kennen es
werden nur wenige elektronen durch den
beta zerfall freigesetzt dies wird meist
durch den einsatz eines kondensators
wettgemacht er legt sich langsam auf und
kann dem strom dann selbst schneller
abgeben
er macht die batterien aber klobig und
sperrig deswegen hat das russische team
auf extrem dünne schichten geachtet
insgesamt misst ihr prototyp nur fünf
mal fünf mal dreieinhalb millimeter
das optimierte system kommt letztendlich
auf 3
300 milliwatt stunden energieprogramm
das ist tatsächlich das zehnfache der
spezifischen energie einer typischen
elektrochemischen batterie ihr maximaler
output beträgt 0,93 mikrowatt dass es
mehr als vergleichbare entwicklung
bislang erreichen konnten
doch dennoch langte es immer noch nicht
um beispielsweise ein smartphone
überhaupt ans laufen zu kriegen
doch in zukunft erhofft sich das
russische forschungsteam vielfältige
einsatzmöglichkeiten und damit wären wir
wieder beim thema herzschrittmachern und
anderen implantaten wenn diese werden
bislang durch elektrochemische batterien
versorgt und wenn diese leer sind müssen
sie durch einen operativen eingriff
entfernt werden ja das ist wirklich ein
bisschen spucke man noch also wenn die
batterie leer ist dann muss ich operiert
werden
ja doch auch hier bietet das große
hindernis erst einmal mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit zu
garantieren dass die radioaktivität die
patienten keinesfalls gefährdet eine
andere durchaus spannende idee ist es
mit solch einer atom batterien
satelliten anzutreiben
denn diese würden dann in betrieb sein
egal ob er sich tim also der satellit im
erdschatten befindet oder nicht die atom
batterien könnten deutlich mehr energie
speichern bzw deutlich kleiner sein als
bisherige batterien für satelliten ja
wenn ihr keine videos sation zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
hättet mich bei whatsapp dann um geht
ihr die kaputte abo boxee auf youtube
und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video und zwar täglich gaben sie ihr
kriegt der von mir ne nachricht bevor es
auf youtube online gehen einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die genau die glocken
vergessen und hier gehts weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken die größte
batterie der welt bis dann bleibt dran